les verriers rois ont bravé le froid et
la pluie pour découvrir l'évolution de
leur ville une balade urbaine était
organisée dans le futur EcoQuartier
garbecane ce samedi 4 février au
programme visite des aménagements du
secteur nord de la gare et son futur
parvis de 6000 mètres carrés l'occasion
aussi de parcourir les terrains des
bécanes situés de l'autre côté de la
voie ferrée ou de nombreuses
constructions verront le jour c'est un
moment de concertation c'est essentiel
pour parler avec les habitants de mieux
cerner leurs attentes de mieux prendre
en considération leur souhait donc c'est
in situ il y a rien de mieux plutôt que
une réunion dans une salle et bien ça
m'intéresse parce que j'aime bien ma
commune parce que j'y habite depuis plus
de 50 ans et ça me fait plaisir de voir
ce qui va maintenant advenir de ce
quartier et oui il faut un café il faut
quelques les choses qui qui attirent les
gens qui font que les gens bougent 1500
logements et 60000 mètres carrés de pôle
d'activités économiques qu'on crée dans
ce futur quartier nouvelle école maison
médicale et près de 25 commerces feront
partie des services proposés l'occasion
d'apporter un nouveau souffle économique
à la commune la grande originalité de ce
projet urbain de cette recueil c'est du
donner un centre un centre-ville et
d'avoir une sorte de mutualisation des
services qui va permettre de donner de
l'attractivité globalement à la ville
grâce à ces constructions des bécanes on
va peut-être avoir une rénovation de
toute Orly parquet 2 puisque ça fait des
années qu'on se bat pour qu'il y ait une
réhabilitation extérieure surtout que ça
commence à être assez vétus des ateliers
de concertation seront organisés avec
les habitants suite à cette balade une
réunion publique en juin clôturera les
discussions permettant le début des
travaux dès 2025 il devrait durer une
quinzaine d'années